vandalized by racists put right today by
the british public
which found its own way to say what it
thinks about intolerance
with flags and messages i thought it was
really important actually
that the boys remember who their hero
is um there's been a lot of talk online
and it might just be a minority but it's
enough to make a lot of noise so i
wanted to
reinforce who rashford not just rashford
but the other black boys particularly
who've been played and were subject to
abuse
we're kings and our kings it's just
really sad that in this day and age
this is still going on and it's on your
doorstep and it's on the tv
it's on social media you can't escape it
the racist abuse
mostly online against black players who
missed penalties in the final of the
euros
was universally condemned today this
mural of marcus rashford became a place
of protest against racism
the artist returned to retouch his work
england players knelt before games to
protest against racism
booed by some england fans at the time
both the prime minister and home
secretary
refused to condemn the booing and priti
patel dismissed taking the knee
as gesture politics england player
tyrone ming's
accused her of stoking the fire as have
opposition mps the home secretary has
some draconian measures and draconian
laws
and the way she talks about migrants and
immigrants
is racist you know it's racist language
that's used to stoke division
i know that the whole house will con
will join me in condemning
the sickening racist abuse directed
last night at our heroic england
football
team on social media the home secretary
yesterday condemned the racism in the
commons
and was defended today by fellow
ministers no one wants to see
racism let's assume that's the case with
everybody including by the way
our home secretary who's been subject in
her life to racism herself no one wants
to see it
and i think we all get behind each other
to defeat it not only in sport but in
society
more broadly pretty patel wore her
england shirt on match day she has
condemned the racist abuse
and she won't like being criticized by a
sporting hero
but there is a view in some sections of
the tory party
that taking the knee is in itself
divisive
too woke and that many of their core
voters
don't really like it so what's the view
in a working man's pub
just round the corner from rashford's
mural the reservations i'm in sport with
the devices them everywhere you go but
you're gonna you're gonna change it by
taking the knee
they can take their knee any time they
want yeah
achieve something fair enough don't
achieve
anything nothing's lost and nothing's
gained
lots of children came today maybe
rashford's free school meals
meant more than the penalty and although
they didn't win the cup
they have inspired people not just to
play football
but to support social change
jason farrell sky news